good evening I am I wanted to come this
evening for a few reasons I guess first
and foremost when I looked on amazon.com
and barnes and noble is buying the lost
son my book so i thought that was cool
and so I want everybody to read this
book so and then they should look at who
buys what the other reason I wanted to
be here is really this gives me an
opportunity to say thank you to someone
that I truly admire and I admire her for
a number of reasons but I guess first
and foremost is because she has helped
the New York City Police Department and
policing around the country probably
more than any one writer could imagine
in 1994 when the mayor took over when
Mayor Giuliani took over this city crime
rates there were some of the highest in
the history of the city on in 1990 there
was some 2245 homicides the city had
sort of the same reputation that Rikers
Island had when I took over in 1995 it
was too big to manage it was too
disorganized there was not efficient
management of the city of the agencies
within the city and in 1994 things
started to change and it primarily
started to change because of a an
internal management system called
ComStat over the next three or four
years crime began to drop substantially
and in doing so you had the
criminologist you had the New York Times
you had people from all over the world
lying blame for crime reductions on
including El Nino at some point but
nobody wanted to say that crime
reduction was really because of the work
that the men and women in the New York
City Police Department was doing in
doing that work it was a great benefit
to the entire city but primarily it was
a benefit to some of the poorest and
some of the minority communities in the
city nobody got it nobody understood it
nobody realized it and it took Heather
McDonald her writing the Manhattan
Institute City Journal it took their
focus in their direction on to get it
out to the public to make people
understand to make people realize that
what was going on in New York City one
was a benefit to the city to the
minority communities to the poorest
communities and I guess to that there
were programs here that could be
replicated all over this country and
that began to happen crime continued to
drop as crime dropped the economy in New
York City started to change when Rudy
Giuliani took over in 1994 the New York
Times and Time Magazine's had polls
those polls basically said that between
45 and 65 percent of the people in New
York City didn't want to live here work
here send the kids to school here on and
if you asked all of those people why
there was one response and that was
crime mayor Giuliani decided that if you
fixed crime if crime started to drop
those issues that people were concerned
about would start to change and they did
the economy started to rise real estate
started to blossom tourism rose to its
highest rates in the history of the city
I think we dropped about seven or eight
hundred thousand people from the welfare
rolls on the entire city started to
change once again Heather McDonald
helped get that out she helped get it
out because two things happen when you
do this and I I'm in the middle of doing
something in Mexico City right now with
the mayor and there are two primary
issues in Mexico City there is crime
actual crime and there is perception
exactly the same two issues that we had
here in New York City crime started the
drop in New York City almost immediately
after Mayor Giuliani took over but
nobody felt it and until they feel it
well it really doesn't make any
difference what happens they they don't
care they have to feel it they have to
perceive it I have to realize it and
sometimes they have to be told over and
over and over and Heather help to do
that one of the other reasons I wanted
to come here was because in I guess I I
wasn't the police guy guess I was able
to I was the police commissioner about
six months and I had been uptown I took
a train uptown up to Harlem I came back
from Harlem I got off of the train at
forty-second Street in seventh Avenue
and I I saw three cops standing on on
the corner I had gotten into my vehicle
and I was in a black suburban with
blacked out windows and I saw these
three cops and there was cars all up and
down forty-second street blocking
traffic and I told my detective that was
sitting in front of me I said to me in
favor I said get that get that sergeant
and have him come over and see me
because I wanted to tell him to move the
cars off of the block and the detective
rolls down the window and he looks out
the window and he says hey Sarge could I
see you for a second at which time I
hear someone say
no well I want to see exactly what he
said but what in close to what he said
was basically no we don't come to you
you come to us you want to talk to us
you get out of the vehicle you come see
us so I says okay I says he wants you to
go to him get out of the vehicle and
tell him I'm in the vehicle and I'm not
getting now sergeant came over to the
vehicle I rolled down my window I said
is that the way you talked to the public
and he just looked at me at which time I
detective said Commissioner wasn't too
sergeant as well who was it he said it
was a police officer well now the
sergeant had two issues one that it was
said and to that it was a subordinate
that said it and that's the board had
fed felt powerful enough or maybe just
not supervised enough that he could talk
to the public like that well I dealt
with the sergeant in the police officer
but I then I think I spoke to Heather
and I spoke to Myron and some others and
I wrote an article about racism racism
and rudeness and how they can be
misconstrued how they could affect
negatively on the impact of the
communities now the detective that went
to those three cops he was Hispanic the
three police officers the two cops and a
sergeant they were Hispanic didn't mean
anything it was just a conversation
negative but it was just a conversation
what if what if i was in harlem what if
those three cops were white what if the
person stopping to ask them a question
was black what if they had the same
response would it be just an arrogant
cop no it would be understood or thought
to be racism
because we're black they're white that's
the way they speak to us there are
racist are they racist no they were
morons they weren't racist
they're not supposed to talk to the
public like that period they're not
supposed to behave like that period it
has nothing to do with race but it could
absolutely be perceived as racism in the
wrong circumstance Heather then comes
along and goes in to the communities
goes into the police department and in
an extremely thorough way talks about
the benefit of the police how difficult
their jobs really how difficult they are
and then how they really impact on the
communities some negative some positive
but what those impacts are and I think
she does so truthfully I think she was
extremely dedicated in her writing and I
think she has been probably more of an
asset to the police department in this
city than she could ever imagine because
people look up to her I have I'm sure
the president Police Commissioner does
the former police commissioner's that I
know have we need to know every aspect
of the way the police department runs
and should run we need advice and
counseling from the communities and from
people like Heather McDonald that can
give us a truthful view on what the cops
are doing what they should be doing and
sometimes what they're not doing and I
think Heather does that so I think if we
wanted to know our comps racist I think
we'd have to ask Heather McDonald
thank you thank you so much I'm
extremely honored and and frankly
relatively speechless by Commissioner
carex kind remarks this is a man who not
only guided New York through the trauma
of 911 but two months later turned
around and published the aforementioned
lost son a fascinating account of his
family background and his life on the
NYPD I don't suppose that Judith Regan
will mind if I mentioned that the book
is now available in paperback and thank
you all for coming tonight strange to
say I know that for many of you this
will be at best merely the second most
important speech you will hear this
evening but I have to admit that I too
will be eager to hear President Bush I
want to hear what he has to say about
Iraq because I know that the fate of the
nation and other nations hangs in the
balance but i'll also be pondering
another very very important question
what effect will a war on iraq have on
book sales does a book about policing
stand a chance of getting noticed if
there is major geopolitical turmoil
maybe only the French will care but
actually the subjects are not so far
apart the war on the police as i call it
has had a crippling effect on law
enforcement and i will argue on the war
on terror to making it harder for us to
be vigilant about protecting ourselves
from catastrophic attack now as
commissioner Carrick is so
extraordinarily eloquently reminded us
New York in the 1990s underwent a wholly
unforeseen Renaissance the major
overriding cause of that comeback was
the
conquest of crime from nineteen ninety
three to two thousand one crime in the
city fell an astounding 64% and New York
roared back to life nowhere was the
crime drop more pronounced as
commissioner Carrick observed than in
New York's poorest neighborhoods in
Harlem murder and burglary dropped over
eighty percent in eight years in the
once drug dominated Washington Heights
murder fell ninety-three percent between
1993 and 2001 as a result the inner-city
witness sites unimaginable ten years ago
twelve-year-old boys trying to learn how
to ride a bike for the first time in
their lives having never before been let
outside middle-class home buyers rushing
to gabble gobble up brownstones in
harlem and disney and other national
retailers opening stores on one hundred
and twenty fifth street let's not forget
what was not seen thousands of coffins
carrying young men to their graves as
would have been the case had the city's
homicides remained at their early 1990s
level of over 2,000 a year how was this
crime route accomplished policing got
smart for the first time in history
commanders were held ruthlessly
accountable for reducing crime in their
precincts police deployment and
strategies were based on the most
up-to-the-minute crime statistics
available and most important the
philosophy of law enforcement underwent
a sea change police would actually
prevent crime not just respond to it but
look what happened next instead of
receiving accolades for their work the
police in New York and indeed across the
country found themselves under siege
here's why
anti-cop groups like the ACLU would get
their hands on some law enforcement
statistics like search or stop rates for
different racial groups these cop
bashing outfits would then compare the
enforcement statistics to population
data if the numbers didn't match
perfectly a cry of police racism would
ring out across the land Rhee doubled
and redoubled by legions of reporters
and politicians let's take a local
example in new york blacks are twenty
five percent of the population but fifty
percent of all stops and frisks
conducted by the NYPD case closed al
Sharpton and his cronies the police are
quote racially profiling a term
concocted by the anti police industry
that has nothing to do with how police
actually work on the streets notice how
the so-called racial profiling analysis
works you compare police data to
population figures such an analysis
would make sense if crime were evenly
distributed across the population but
the facts are these in New York blacks
are 13 times more likely to commit a
violent assault than whites according to
victim identifications they commit about
62 percent of violent attacks so at
fifty fifty percent of all stops and
frisks they're actually being under
stopped this disproportion unfortunately
exists in every city and county across
the country in Arlington County Virginia
for example blacks are ten percent of
the population but they commit seventy
percent of all robberies according to
victim IDs there's seven times more
likely to commit homicide nationally
than whites and Hispanics combined this
disparity has multiple compound
in consequences for the law enforcement
data that the ACLU and other groups so
obsessively scrutinize for racial
disparities it means for example that
when the police are looking for violent
crime suspects they will overwhelmingly
be stopping black and Hispanic men based
again not on police racism but victim
identifications those stops will be
recorded and later gleefully seized upon
by the ACLU or the NAACP but do they
show racial profiling of course not the
police are going where the crime is
disparate crime rates also mean that
when police target resources to the
highest crime neighborhoods in order to
save lives they will be going to largely
minority neighborhoods once their
so-called racial profiling is irrelevant
because most of the people living there
are of the same race but crime rates
well essential are just the start of
what you need to know if you really are
going to analyze police data properly
for alleged racism or so-called racial
profiling you also need details about
police deployment location of crime
hotspots the number of young people in
different populations and the
demographics of roads and highways which
change hourly there's a host of other
factors which i'm not going to burden
you with but they're mind-bogglingly
complex none of them has been
acknowledged by the so-called racial
profiling crusaders but the biggest
taboo has unquestionably been the effect
of civilian law breaking on police
statistics for criminologist or
sociologists to even suggest studying it
was to commit professional suicide last
year researchers in Maryland broke the
taboo and produced a groundbreaking and
highly sophisticated study of speeding
behavior on the New Jersey Turnpike it
found that black drivers were twice as
likely to speed as white drivers a
difference it only increased at speeds
over 90 miles an hour this I think goes
a good way to explain the different stop
rates that are persistently recorded by
the New Jersey State Troopers well what
happened to this study the Bush
administration did everything within its
powers to bury it and it only saw the
light of day when it was leaked to the
web now on the basis of these
statistical studies that wouldn't earn
an F in a freshman statistics course the
Clinton Justice Department in the 1990s
went around the country slapping consent
decree on City after City on county and
state after county after state requiring
police departments to compile exhaustive
racial and ethnic data about their
officers every interaction with
civilians the presumption behind these
data collection mandates was that the
police not criminals were the country's
main law enforcement problem even cities
and states that it somehow escaped a
federal monitor impose their own data
collection mandates on their officers
the effect of this crusade has been
devastating on a practical level the
task of collecting and compiling vast
amounts of racial data now being
generated on the streets has sucked
hundreds thousands of officers off of
patrol duty and spit them out into
offices where they're busily trying to
compile the data for the Justice
Department to overseer for their own
local police monitors at a time when the
threat of terrorism and rising crime
eight rates makes manpower on the
streets of vital necessity but more
profoundly the anti-cop juggernaut has
sent the message to officers that if
they have quote too many interactions
with minorities it's because they're
racist not because they're trying to do
their jobs in good faith
to a cop on the beat the current
situation feels ironic to say the least
for decades the racial rap against
policing was that it ignored crime in
poor neighborhoods and unfortunately
this charge was often justified now
thanks to the the innovations of
departments like the NYPD and
data-driven policing such unconscionable
neglect is a thing of the past but when
departments respond to the heartfelt
demands of law-abiding inner city
residents for Public Safety they'll
inevitably generate law enforcement data
that will be used by anti-cop advocates
to prove their racism many officers have
responded by shutting down police morale
across the country has been crushed by
the years of cop bashing in the media in
City after City stops and arrests have
fallen dramatically following a racial
profiling hysteria and crime has shot up
in 2001 in Cincinnati there were
anti-cop riots in the spring followed by
a international storm of media attention
claiming that the Cincinnati Police were
egregiously biased what happened in the
summer Cincinnati became a bloodbath it
was like the Wild West they'd never seen
such levels of violent crime the victims
needless to say were almost entirely
young black men Pittsburgh which got the
second federal consent decree in the
country they're the officers report
making arrests by quota since each
individual officer is now tagged for his
interactions and arrests based on the
race of the civilians officers say if
they've reached their quota for black
arrest that month they'll stop and start
looking for white people to arrest in
Maryland over the last eight years
druggin or drug interdictions
the highways have dropped ninety percent
now my guess is that drug trafficking
didn't go down a comparable amount what
happened was again they have been under
litigation for racial profiling for the
nearly eight years now let me clarify
what I am NOT saying i am not advocating
racial profiling i don't think the cops
do it I don't think they need to do it
my claim is that the statistical
evidence that has been proffered again
and again isn't worth the paper it's
written on it's worse than junk science
are they're lazy cops who use race as a
proxy for criminality of course and they
should be ferreted out and retrained but
is police racism the endemic problem
that the New York Times and the ACLU
would have us believe absolutely not the
real problem as commissioner Carrick is
pointed out is courtesy the officers
need a little training in manners
frankly they face an enormous challenge
in in retaining their civility they see
the worst of human nature they're under
constant assault from people on the
street but all the more reason why they
have to learn to treat people
respectfully if we could take care of
that problem I think many of the others
would fall away but I have to say that I
think that if every cop were struck
colorblind today I don't think that the
law enforcement data that the ACLU
relies upon so heavily would look a
whole lot different another thing that i
am not saying I am NOT saying that the
majority of blacks and Hispanics in this
country are lawbreakers to the contrary
the majority obey the law with respect
and they desire public safety as much as
anybody else the
ludacris aspect of that profiling
juggernaut is that it purported to be
about helping inner-city residents well
that not according to the ones that I've
talked to go to any police community
meeting and the only thing you'll hear
is bring us more cops why aren't you
getting the drug dealers off the streets
why are you allowing these guys to
loiter as I've discovered inner-city
residents aren't really big fans of most
supreme court decisions on Criminal
Procedure including the evisceration of
loitering laws and and many others that
I'm not going to go into mayor Giuliani
I held a town hall meeting in Harlem in
2001 this was unfortunately his first
trip up to the city up to that part of
the city and I would have expected and
I'm sure all of you would have expected
that given the previous eight years of
press coverage the the world war two
level New York Times coverage of the
Diallo tragedy and the subsequent
coverage of the dorsum on shooting that
there would have been won unanimous cry
to Mayor Giuliani to call off the cops a
complaints about police brutality and
profiling well I I actually have a tape
from the from the meeting and I I urge
you all to look at it it's quite
instructive the only thing believe
people complained about was that
Giuliani hadn't done enough to bring
crime down there the man was poor guys
saying but wait a minute I've got the
statistics I can show you eighty percent
down in Harlem what are you talking
about always see his drug dealers get
him out one man actually asked Charles
Rangel to declare a state of emergency
not a guess appreciating who it was he
was addressing
support for the police in minority
neighborhoods is wholly unreported by
the mainstream media but it's easy to
find in Cincinnati I spoke to a
middle-aged woman named Sheila Randall
who'd wanted to attend a Prokop
demonstration but she was terrified to
go out of her house because of the young
anti-cop rabble what about the charge
that the police haul over every black
men they can find for a gratuitous stop
and frisk well earlier this month I was
in south central LA in gang territory
and I spoke to a charles Jenkins a
father of four he told me I've never had
any problems with the police but I've
never done anything to create problems
if you're not violating the law you have
nothing to worry about is this naive
maybe but I've heard this sentiment more
times than I can count now if you
disable the police with false
accusations of racism you're going to
consign vast numbers of hard-working
inner-city residents to a life of fear
but the devastation wrought by the
anti-cop forces is not confined to poor
neighborhoods I think it also hampered
the war on terror the fiction underlying
the anti profiling crusade domestically
is that all groups commit crime at equal
rates well that fiction has been carried
over to the anti-terrorism context where
it reads all groups commit Islamic
terrorism at equal rates in 1996 a
commission on airline security chaired
by then Vice President Al Gore
explicitly issued any consideration of a
passenger's national origin ethnicity or
even Jen
in assessing his terrorism risk under
loud pressure from the
anti-discrimination and Arab lobby
needless to say those are just the
factors which are major predictors of
anti-american Islamic terrorism this
emasculated passenger screening system
was in place on 911 had it reflected
reality and not political correctness I
think there is a chance that at least
some of the hijackers would have been
flagged that day remember FBI agent
Kenneth Williams this was the good man
in Arizona who in May of 2001 sent a
memo up to his supervisor saying that he
had several al-qaeda operatives under
surveillance who were in American
aviation academies and he suggested that
the FBI check out other Arab men in
flight schools the memo was promptly
shelved now the situation with the FBI
is very complicated but I am convinced
that one of the reasons was simply a
prophylactic political shall we say
bottom covering imagine what would have
happened if word had leaked out that the
FBI was checking out Arab men from the
Middle East enrolled in flight schools
for possible terrorism connections I
think there probably would have been
headlines the New York Times The
Washington Post The Boston Globe the Los
Angeles Times excoriating the FBI for
its racism now the consequences of the
absurd fiction that all groups commit
Islamic terrorism at equal rates has
affected individual law enforcement
officers as well in the weeks before
nine eleven a Maryland state trooper
stopped one of the nine eleven hijackers
for a traffic violation the driver was
acting extremely nervously and
suspiciously and the troopers
the his his instincts were raised by
this but he didn't pursue it why because
as I mentioned Maryland is one of the
states that has been the one of the
battlegrounds for racial profiling and
he wasn't about to leave himself open to
charges of racism well we'd better start
reassuring our officers that they will
not be made scapegoats for crime or
terrorism problems not of their own
making if we expect to be safe in the
future the Bush administration to its
credit has started taking tiny baby
steps towards acknowledging the
different parts of the world and
different religious groups pose
different levels of threat of Islamic
terrorism each of these steps has been
greeted by howls of outrage by the
nation's political and media elites I
think if the country's opinion makers
were to discard the fiction of equal
rates of terrorism the government's
actions would be far more decisive and
effective now in conclusion I want to
draw two lessons from the tribulations
of policing in the last decade and of
course it's not just tribulations as
commissioner Carrick reminded us the
victories have been enormous but
unfortunately they've been marred by by
the unjustified criticism the first
lesson I want to draw is that we let bad
ideas fester at our own risk as the
racial profiling crusade heated up in
the 1990s no one dared oppose or
question its premises because supporting
the crusade against racial profiling was
an easy way to show one's racial good
faith President Bush engaged in these
politics himself but now a construct
that was bogus to begin with is
intruding itself into a battle even more
serious than the war on crime the second
lesson
we should stop conducting surrogate
politics the whole hysteria about racial
profiling has been driven by one
overriding imperative to avoid talking
about elevated rates of crime in
inner-city communities instead of
confronting that problem head-on we've
blamed the messenger the police for
bringing news we'd rather cover up but I
can tell you if 150th of the time spent
over the last decade discussing police
racism 150th of the conflict the racial
profiling conference time I've attended
more than I would like to say of the
white paper time of the TV time of the
news reporting time of the bloviating
time if 150th of that had been spent
trying to figure out how to prevent
young minority males from dropping out
of school and taking up guns and drugs
we would not have been having the racial
profiling debate to begin with if al
Sharpton and Jesse Jackson for once had
the courage to march on a jail cell that
held a racist who'd been violating
minority women or a robber who stole the
Social Security check of elderly Harlem
residents instead of marching against
the police we wouldn't be here today you
know mix a mixed response for me but I'd
rather not be here if we could if we
could solve the crime problem so I want
to end with a suggestion to my
colleagues in the media world you don't
have to listen to Al Sharpton and Jesse
Jackson
go into the inner city you'll find
eloquent magisterial voices calling for
personal responsibility and a respect
for law and order people like babe Baker
and Tom Jones in Cincinnati who I've had
the privilege to meet or old John
Williams in Indianapolis unfortunately
until now the elites have not bothered
to listen to such people if they did
we'd all be looking forward to a better
future thank you very much now I've been
asked that you guys have to use your own
mic to to get this all on tape Michael I
was waiting for this Eric comes all
right executive director of New York
Civil Rights Coalition and in terms of
public disclosure I am formally
assistant national director for the
n-double-a-cp as well as I am currently
I am currently a member of the american
civil liberties union national board of
directors i also i am also a past member
of mayor Giuliani's task force on police
community relations I was surprised that
among the anti-cop bashers bashing
groups you did not mention was the
Attorney General of New York State
because he also issued to a devastating
report speaking of the ratio impact or
the racial disparate impact with respect
to stop and frisk by police officers in
New York but that's not my question you
don't have to I put to you that you
don't have to be a racist in order to
engage in misconduct at the police
officer and since most contacts are with
young minority youth it appears that
have a racially disparate impact and
misconduct sometimes is based on racial
stereotype and as you know
a police officer must have a reasonable
suspicion as a basis for stopping
someone on the street that that person
has or is about to commit a crime a
reasonable suspicion yet still innocent
minority use like white use hang out on
street corners innocent minority youths
like white use go to malls to hang out
as well as to shop innocent minority
youth and particularly young black men
go into stores to shop but so frequently
they're followed by the security guard
because of racial stereotype and so
frequently they're stopped by police
officers they can stand out in front of
school public schools and told to move
on but when you look at the white
neighborhoods to high-class high status
middle-income white areas young white
children do not complain about that kind
of illegal move on orders and so I guess
my question to you is if there is a
question to this why are you so certain
that this issue is a question of cops
being racist it was a colonel Commission
for example in 1960s that get discovered
that minority use in their social
gatherings being harassed by bike ups
there have been report after report
after report documenting misconduct by
police officers visa vie young minority
youth who have not been involved in
crime we have not been either under
suspicion or arrested for crime so I
think that when particularly you look at
the difference between black police
officers and white police officers who
engage and use lethal force the
differences are tremendous in turn
statistics so I suggest I suggest to you
that there is a there is a bigger
problem it turns a racial stereotype and
disparity in terms of treatment of young
minority people in American society
which has a legacy and discrimination
and stereotype and racial prejudice well
that's a lot Michael of New York
Attorney General's report I think it
suffers from many of the same flaws that
i mentioned as far as
capturing the extraordinary number of
details that you need to take into your
statistical model if you're going to
start comparing police data black and
white police officers in fact the
greatest use of force by police officers
is against members of their own race and
in most places the police's black and
white officers stopped minorities at
identical rates black officers face an
added burden when they're on the streets
it's it's really very poignant because
they are constantly accused of racial
profiling being black doesn't insulate
them from the same charges that white
officers face they're accused of selling
out of being an Uncle Tom you know cut
me a break and you know that somebody
will say you only a black officer in
Brooklyn I talked to several they were
extraordinary detectives they'll pull
somebody over who is violating lon said
you only stop me because I'm black their
responses no I stopped you because you
ran a red light or I stopped you because
he stole the lady's purse there's two
sorts of evidence Michael for the charge
of endemic police racism the anecdotes
and the statistics you give me anecdotes
of our claims of large large numbers of
innocent black men that are being hauled
over for no reason at all I can go and
give you anecdotes of young black men
that I've talked to say I've never been
stopped because I don't run with the
wrong crowd and I'm not on a drug corner
at 2am so we can get into warring
anecdotes has there been a problem of
police racism in the past absolutely
especially in the south but here there
was abuse of force but I think that over
the last several decades policing has
become professionalized it has learned a
far better code of conduct and I don't
think officers are engaged in the sorts
of brutal behavior that was once common
the Abner Louie
mckay's was was such a horrific event in
part thank heavens because it was so
rare but this so you've got the
anecdotes and that's that's a hard thing
to to to mediate your one falls back on
the statistical studies and again there
i say to date none have been done that
are anything other than junk science so
again you know maybe from the person who
stopped perspective it looks like
they're doing nothing wrong but i would
like to know were they standing on a
known drug corner was there a robbery
pattern did they fit the description of
a suspect were the police in the
neighborhood for a intensive crime
strategy that was targeting quality of
life offenses in an effort to find find
somebody that as a far greater risk to
the community there's so many factors
that i think it's it's hard to
generalize again i'm not i'm not going
to deny that there are abuses of power
but my point again is this is all we've
been discussing for the last couple s
decade it's all we've been discussing if
we're going to discuss the police let's
also discuss how to bring crime down
because the two problems are
inextricably linked jogger case heather
the report in today's paper especially i
haven't read the police report i've only
glanced at it i I do know that the final
court decision I think was railroaded
through the initial date that had been
set for a court decision was in February
the defendants attorneys asked that it
be moved up till January and then
without warning to the police the judge
made his decision in December before the
police had an opportunity to present
their side of the story
you know I think we all should read the
report and again I don't I don't think
it's appropriate to comment now on what
I think happened until I've looked
through it Henry I think you and I think
I think you but perhaps others have
written that the reason that the FBI was
see I were inhibited in cashing the Arab
terrorists was a set of regulations in
1995 imposed by Janet Reno imposing a
Chinese wall on the description
dissemination of information could you
tell us about that and perhaps give us
some insights of yours as to what
motivated Janet Reno during her
eight-year tenure as attorney general
the United States man first I have to be
a police expert next to Janet Reno
expert I'm just going to stick with the
first question Henry in in 1995 attorney
General Janet Reno imposed perhaps the
most terrifying set of restrictions on
intelligence gathering and utilization
that you could possibly imagine it was
dubbed the wall and it meant that two
FBI agents in new york city's downtown
headquarters on the same al-qaeda squad
couldn't talk to each other about an
anti-terror case if one of them were
gathering wiretap information under a
federal statute known as the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act and the
other one was pursuing a criminal case
against a terrorist this wall developed
this completely artificial hothouse
distinction between terror and
telligence and terror law enforcement a
distinction that doesn't make sense I
you know when somebody takes a airplane
and uses it to destroy buildings and
lives they've committed a crime as well
as and get engaged in an act of
terrorism and we need every single
member of the americas law enforcement
community be they they call themselves a
prosecutor if they call themselves a
criminal agent if they call themselves
an intelligence analyst everybody has to
be sharing everything they know about
al-qaeda but because of the wall you had
such absurdities well the car is Mousawi
case the alleged 20th hijacker who was
flagged by alert FBI agents in
minneapolis and they sought to get a
warrant to search his personal effects
in the weeks before 911 because of the
effect of this wall which which imposed
penalties on intelligence agents if they
just talk to each other about a wiretap
and tried to try to understand what a
terrace estimate was saying the
bureaucracy had become so gun-shy so
terrified of the consequences of
violating the wall that the FBI
bureaucracy said sorry we're not going
to give you your warrant they imposed
much higher probable cause standards
than the law even requires in in the
days before nine eleven it finally came
out that kalid Almeida who was a al
Qaeda operative had gotten into the
country and was loose and and the FBI
got word of this and wanted to initiate
a massive dragnet for him well
headquarters FBI headquarters told FBI
agents in New York that they couldn't
look for Almeida why because they were
technically criminal terror agents and
Almeida hadn't yet been indicted for
a crime so they could only use
technically intelligence agents well a
few days later Alma darwood commandeer
american airlines flight 77 into the
Pentagon I think the wall was the final
a grotesque culmination of decades of
attempts to handcuff the nation's
anti-terror forces based on such
ludicrous distinctions as this between
the investing intelligence investigation
and the law enforcement intelligent
investigation of spies and terrorists
and it grows out of I think you're right
to bring up the analogy a similar phobia
about law enforcement that has spread
into domestic policing fortunately john
ashcroft did try to lift the wall he was
initially blocked in that by a federal
judge that oversees these foreign
intelligence wiretaps but thank heavens
for appellate courts occasionally they
do get it right and and the wall has
been lifted making possible the type of
coordination between law enforcement
intelligence that is essential if we are
going to actually break the al Qaeda
cells that I think are probably still in
the country I'm Bob cressey Heather in
your remarks you rather I think
pointedly stated that in anti-terrorism
especially with SLI mecke terrorism that
profiling is perfectly appropriate and I
think everyone has probably seen the
email it has gone around ad nauseam
about the 10 or 15 characteristics of
who might be a Islamic terrorism and it
all comes into somebody under 40 male
and from an Arabic country yet you also
gave us some very telling statistics
about minority crime in the incidence of
this crime in the country yet you seem
to say
hey we shouldn't be profiling and it
seems to me that if you are seventy
percent sure that the criminal or
perpetrator is a young minority person
who should the cops be looking for in a
in a shooting in a hip after-hours hip
hop black Club at 4am who should the
police be looking for I am so glad you
asked that question because I didn't
know whether to make the distinction
during my regular talk or not because it
gets pretty complicated but absolutely i
distinguish the two i oppose one and i
support the other for the following
reason again I don't think the police
are racially profiling but but this is
how it works according to the ACLU in
the domestic law enforcement context
what so-called racial profiling is all
about is simply playing the odds
everybody commits robberies everybody
commits homicides but what the ACLU
claims the police are doing is saying
well because the stats said statistics
show us blacks and Hispanics are more
likely in fact often far more likely to
commit robberies or homicides than
whites will play the odds and and focus
our attention on blacks I don't think
that's fair and again I don't think it's
necessary because the police do have
contextual cues if they make a car
stopped on a highway for instance and
they're deciding whether to ask for
consent search to look for drugs they
don't need race what can they look for
do the guys in the car even know each
other's names do they even agree why
they're on the road one you pull them
apart and one guy will say oh yeah we're
going up to visit Jose's aunt in in
Bethesda and somebody else had no we're
on our way to Boston they didn't get
their story straight they they'll
nervously looks at the amount of luggage
so I don't think you need race terrorism
Islamic terrorism profiling as far as
I'm concerned is a completely different
issue it
not playing the odds it's following a
logical tautology to its inevitable
conclusion Osama bin Laden did not call
on Catholics or Jews to kill every
American wherever they find them he
called on muslims I I don't even know
what it means to look for Islamic
terrorists in the non Islamic community
but i'll tell you how how deeply the
fiction that all groups commit Islamic
terrorism and equal rates is gone I had
the privilege of interviewing new york's
new intelligence chief this summer David
Cohen who's from the CIA and I asked him
if the the political environment allows
him to surveil some of the city's more
radical mosques and he told me and let's
just hope he was choosing his words
deceptively in speaking to the press he
said he has no way of distinguishing why
he would go to a mosque and not a
Catholic Church this is insanity with
all due respect to David Cohen and I I
hope and I think in light of the NYPD's
appeal of a highly restrictive consent
decree from the 1970s that limits their
intelligence gathering the Honshu
agreement I think maybe that they are
not they're acting differently than
they're speaking but again I would like
somebody to explain to me and I've had
this debate as well with with members of
the ACLU what is possibly to be gained
by spreading are always finite always
inadequate law enforcement resources
equally across all religious groups are
all national origin groups again let's
face it
our policies in the Middle East are
highly controversial and we are at risk
from people that violently disagree I
don't think a lutheran from Minnesota or
a Southern Baptist from Mississippi is
going to be moved to take as many
American lives because of America's role
in Saudi Arabia or the Middle East so as
I say in the one case you're playing the
odds in the other you are simply taking
Osama bin Laden at his words and and
following what is a logical necessity
thank you